the challenges
facing our world are growing all the
time
how do we build stronger economies with
equal opportunities for all
how do we build a sustainable world for
generations to come
how do we protect our cities and harness
the power of technology for our common
benefit
humanity has always been good at forward
thinking
in this series using the latest
bloomberg research and analysis
we will make sense of the problems of
tomorrow sustainability
urbanization the gender gap
the march of the machines and the
demographic time bomb and in this film
inequality it's the issue that
preoccupies economists
politicians and campaigners what does it
mean for the security of our societies
and the strength of our economies
[Music]
our world is a divided and unequal place
in a competitive economy you will always
have some inequality
and obviously you'll have those who are
very successful and some who are less so
but the
issue is the extreme one percent of the
wealthiest population
holds more than half of the world's
wealth
62 wealthiest people hold
the same kind of wealth as the lowest
50 percent of the world population it's
a very striking statistic indeed
if you look at ceo pay you know it's
gone from
about 50 times the average worker 30
years ago
to 300 times now potentially not only
does it issue for investors it's also an
issue for
for workers
[Music]
inequality has become the hot button
economic issue of the 21st century
but worrying about inequality is not new
if we look way back into u.s history we
saw
dramatic income inequality in for
instance the gilded age the 1880s and
the 1890s
and it went so far and then it collapsed
and policies were put in place
by a number of presidents and
administrations
to sort of uh equalize the playing field
uh labor laws were put in place tax laws
were changed
and that prevailed through the course of
world war ii and into the 1960s
but then by the 1980s tax laws were
changed and
the economy had changed and so from
the early 1980s to present we've seen
income
inequality on the rise it matters
because
income inequality eventually contributes
uh to wealth inequality with wealth
comes power in terms of politics and
corporate leadership and lots of
different facets of the economy and so
when
much wealth is held by a very few
individuals within an economy or within
a country
then those individuals tend to have an
outsized
degree of control over economic and
political policy making and therefore
they are
able to incorporate policies that will
even further
increase their levels of wealth
inequality is about more than fairness
economists worry extreme levels of
inequality can have dramatic effects on
the finances of corporations
and governments it
really affects the pace at which
uh well the world economy is growing so
uh to give you an example the wealthiest
as they
get more money they tend to spend less
of a marginal dollar
so this way you get less consumption and
consequently
less growth in the economy so that's one
uh
kind of a consequence another thing is
that lower
and medium income families tend to
borrow
more to support their consumption and it
creates
risks some of the most dramatic levels
of inequality can be seen in the
developing world
here inequality appears to have a
corrosive effect on the whole economy
something else that we've seen in
emerging markets is a correlation
between
inequality and corruption levels
where government is not effective you
aren't necessarily getting education in
place and the rules
to allow everyone to succeed if you look
at the arab spring in north africa and
the middle east
you know at root cause was you know
economic opportunity
and so if you have this extreme
inequality if you have a lack of
economic opportunity you know you could
potentially have a political unrest
if you're at the top of the pile it's
tempting to think inequality does not
affect you
but this may be dangerously complacent
clearly inequality is very bad for the
people at the bottom especially if the
bottom
is very low i think at the top there's a
potential risk to
you know what what could extreme
inequality breed
could it lead to political unrest um
could it lead to new rules
new taxation so i think you know in the
short term
even if you're at the the top of the
economic permit
you may be very happy with your position
but long term i think
there's potential for for change which
may be destabilizing
if you think about it in a broader sense
and
think about economic growth and future
generations
it's a bad thing because that actually
could
impact economic growth uh in in the
world
so i would say that it's a it's a
problem for everybody
one global economist is convinced
inequality is dramatically affecting
human life
in even the richest parts of the world
and that if we want to maximize growth
and social cohesion
it's an issue we can no longer ignore
absolute income inequality is where i
think we have to have a real debate
there are clear knock-on effects and
whether there are an education
access healthcare options
but also political and life expectancy
challenges it's very much the case that
income inequality is now a driver
in some of these other factors
[Music]
inequality is one of the most hotly
debated issues in economics
from new york to nairobi dambisa moyo
is a global economist her work for the
world bank
and on wall street has seen her named
one of the most influential people in
the world
she's fascinated by the biggest trends
in economics
from the politics of development in
africa to the price of commodities in
china
now she's turning her attention to
inequality
[Music]
income inequality is particularly
problematic
inasmuch as it is a defining factor
in many societies for where a society's
living standards are going
the date on income inequality has shown
that it has gotten worse
over the last several decades
in fact over the past 30 years we have
seen income inequality worsen
across the united states the united
kingdom and across much of
europe in the same vein we've seen that
the average income of the top one
percent in the united states today
is 30 times the average income of the
rest of the populations and the rest of
the 99 percent
um compare this with 30 years ago in
1978
when it was simply 10 times higher for
the
top 1
[Music]
economists worry that inequality ushers
in a range of social problems
recent studies in mexico suggest that
neighborhoods with high levels of
inequality
may suffer more violent crime than those
where inequality is less pronounced
researchers in other nations have come
to similar conclusions
a problem with income inequality is the
implications and impact that it has on a
society
and the question being is it possible
for people of different income levels
and without
prospects of improving their lives to
live cheek by zhao
for example in the united states the
bronx
is the poorest congressional district in
the united states
but it's also 20 minutes by train about
five stops
to one of the richest enclaves in the
world in the upper east side of
manhattan
there are real questions around whether
that sort of a living
cheek by gel is actually long-term
sustainable
given risks of crime and also
destitution
there are knock-on effects for other
forms of inequality such as health or
education
and of course political inequality
in the united states approximately 158
families
are responsible for approximately 50
percent of campaign funding
um around the u.s election system and
that really does
pose the question about where democracy
stands and how that might play in to the
political
representation of the democratic process
americans have always prided themselves
on levels of social mobility within
their country
the ability of people to get ahead
whatever circumstances they were born
into
but some recent evidence suggests this
is changing
there is a more fundamental aspect to
dealing
with the incoming inequality challenge
which i would argue revolves around
social mobility
and social mobility really is about
people's belief and people's
access and opportunity to improving
their living standards and their
livelihoods over
a period of time i think that the cause
of income inequality is the breakdown
of social mobility particularly in
western societies so just to give you a
flavor for that
today in the united states if you are
born into the bottom
20 of the income level then you have
only 5 chance of ending up your life in
the top 20
without the college degree clearly that
suggests that income inequality is
widening
and i think also it shows that there's a
real issue around social mobility and
people's ability
to actually transform their lives and to
move into higher levels of income
[Music]
as well as hindering social mobility
extreme levels of income inequality
may depress growth across whole
economies
the reason that this is so important is
that the oecd
estimates that this is costing those
developed countries approximately eight
and a half percent
gdp points um over this period
so put another way because of income
inequality and the widening effects
of the gap between the richest and the
poorest in the
u.s and across europe we have seen gdp
growth
slow by about 8.5 percent over the past
25 years today um there are real
concerns
about how this bodes for the longer term
and for the future
a lot of projections now show that
economic growth will be slowing
and obviously the knock-on effects of
income inequality are likely to be worse
this means inequality is not just a
problem for those at the bottom of the
economic pile
chronic income inequality may well
affect the social
and economic health of everyone
if you are wealthy and living in a uh in
an
urban setting for example the fact that
you
every day are dealing with people who
have a lower income
levels but more importantly have fewer
prospects to improve their livelihoods
has an absolute direct impact on your
safety
but also on your own living standards to
the extent that society
as a whole will not likely be growing
and so
it's not just about lower living
standards for those
that proportion of societies about lower
living standards
for its entirety in the society because
the growth of a society
is highly linked to how the average
person in society is performing
[Music]
dambisa believes the key to tackling
inequality
lies in reactivating social mobility but
to do that
citizens basic needs in terms of health
and education
must be catered for first i think that
the thing that is a paramount an
urgency is to ensure that all citizens
and particularly people who are at the
lower levels of income
are seeing improvements in their living
standards over the long period of time
the real underlying challenges of income
and equality in a broader sense which i
would argue really are hitched
to the idea of social mobility and the
challenges there
but social mobility is propelled by
economic growth
and without economic growth inequality
will rise
just to be absolutely clear on that we
need to aim for at least seven percent
gdp growth every year in order to double
per capita incomes in one generation
we are far below that target so it's
really the case
that we do have real issues around what
the long-term prospects
for economic growth are but therefore
what the long-term prospects for social
mobility and our ability to reduce
income inequality are
[Music]
if the problem of inequality is worrying
for the west
then it's compounded in countries with
fast-growing young populations
if these economies are to have any
chance of tackling inequality
they must create millions of jobs first
beyond just the developed countries of
course there's a real concern around
income inequality widening particularly
in the faster growing
largest emerging market economies such
as brazil india and south africa
today there are approximately 85 million
young people
mainly in the emerging markets between
the ages of 18 and 25 that are out of
work
if we are going to try and solve the
income inequality challenge we first
have to make sure we've got growth but
we also have to make sure
that we are providing incomes that are
growing
um to this young population
we also have to make sure that people
have improved access to education and to
health care
so that they have the social
infrastructure to improve their lives
and therefore support
social mobility without those factors
there is a real risk that living
standards of not just the impoverished
percentage of the population but society
as a whole starts to deteriorate
[Music]
south africa is one of the most unequal
countries
in the world here the consequences of
inequality on the safety of society are
visible
and real but businesses are trying to
restart social mobility
and save the economy
[Music]
inequality is one of the defining
challenges of our age
in south africa the most unequal country
on the continent
its consequences can be seen in the
continuing poverty
of large parts of the country and
in the visceral fear of crime that
defines the wealthiest suburbs
taking a look at the big picture uh and
the
the well-being of a country in the long
run uh it is
very unhealthy to have this dramatic
distribution of
of wealth and inequality it will not be
a successful model to live in a world
where the haves are
isolated into communities with very high
walls around those communities while
the have-nots are sitting at the gates
begging for table scraps
[Music]
in south africa there are more private
security guards than police officers
they patrol the country's gated suburbs
under the most visible example
of an unequal society crime is bad
in your home out of your home
basically all over i don't want it to
sound like it's terrifying we live with
it and
we have good lives here however trying
to keep
your family safe trying to keep your
home safe has become
more and more difficult and that is what
we focus on
css tactical is a johannesburg-based
private security firm
employing 750 people
so our approach is very much multiple
layers of security so you would have
your armed response you would have your
proactive patrolling so
the vehicle is not just sitting under a
tree waiting to be dispatched
they're actually present in the area
they're patrolling they're driving
up and down streets and we've got very
intelligent software that actually
alerts on
unusual behavior so if you're walking
down the streets
five o'clock in the afternoon going home
from work that's normal but three
o'clock in the morning on that side of
the street is abnormal so there's again
a tension on what is going on in the
suburb as opposed to just sitting under
a tree waiting for
an alarm to go fear of crime
is splitting johannesburg in two the
city experienced over 21 000 burglaries
last year
johannesburg is the financial capital so
hence a
greater concentration of i guess wealth
and wealthy people
and lots of stuff to steal lots of stuff
that can that you can see to steal
there's a massive difference between the
haves and the have-nots
i mean unemployment is rife and i think
unfortunately people have not seen that
you know crime is is a way to make a
living
south africa is now more unequal than it
was
under apartheid but some businesses
across the country
are actively trying to address this and
get social mobility
moving again so i was pregnant with my
first daughter
and i was at home we lived in a farm so
i was at home during the day and i would
chat to the ladies that worked in the
fields next door and that sort of thing
and they were picking lettuces and
whatever
but they really had you know that they
would they had so much inside of them
but they had no opportunity to go
anywhere there was no opportunity for
training
or to to get a bit further or anything
and also what i realized there was no
power of possibility
erin along with her sister maeve decided
to set up mangua nani
a health spa their plan was to recruit
their staff
from among the rural poor
it was literally there's a couple of
ladies from the field next door so
everybody went home and found sisters
and aunts and whatever they were
unemployed and of course we trained them
up
i realized the importance and what
manganani could actually do in south
africa i realized that very very quickly
and realizing then the amount of lives
you could change
[Music]
christine boudelesi was one of the first
women that erin and maeve employed
i was on my way i remember one weekend
going to church
then i met maeve who gave me a lift and
she started chatting to me are you
working what are you doing at the moment
i was still at school and everything
then i said to her no currently i'm
working at a farm it was a chicken farm
where we were paid like 20 rent a day
then she said but why don't you come and
join mango
then after a week i said you know what
i've got nothing to use
so i went for my training then from
there started working at the spa as a
therapist
i started from the bottom like doing
massages which
i really enjoyed it then within three
months and i moved into
becoming one of the treaty managers and
then i think within a year
i was promoted to be a general manager
which for me
it was such a growth in such a small
time
nangwanani has become a prolific job
creation scheme
expanding across south africa and
propelling women like christine from
rural poverty to senior managerial
positions
we estimate that we've trained about 20
000 people
we had ladies that had been with us for
say eight nine years
and it really reached the top they were
now managers and i'm also proud to say
that
every single one of our spots is run by
a lady
who came up through the ranks
[Music]
erin is going further rolling out plans
across her 20 spas to give shares in the
business to its employees
at the moment in quesadilla tell our
staff own 30
of their business i wanted them to be
part of the business
because when you're doing that many
treatments in a day you're giving so
much of yourself
by training staff giving them a route to
move up the pay grades and offering the
mistake in their own business
erin hopes her firm can help tackle
inequality in south africa
i can look after my kids i can look
after my family
you know with us black communities we've
got so many families that
we take care of like i'm a breadwinner
at home
everybody depends on me as much as
you've got the other people that are
are working but most of the time i'm the
one who's taking that
whole responsibility so mango nani has
given us
like growth like giving us hope
it has made us like dreamers
inequality has come to define south
africa's economy but if more can be done
to reactivate social mobility
there's a chance that this will not be
the case for long
when households are really in a grinding
state of poverty
they can't contribute a whole lot uh to
economic well-being so
as lower income demographics are lifted
up into
working class or middle class thresholds
they tend to be better educated there's
less crime
there's a stronger family structure and
they tend to be a lot more productive
in terms of the economy and they also
consume and invest a lot more as well
a strong middle class a strong working
class
is really the backbone of a healthy
democracy
i feel i'm cautiously optimistic about
the future
i believe that the path towards a world
of economic growth
of social mobility and improved
income inequality statistics is one that
is possible but not without there
being hard choices whether it's
increasing economic growth
increasing social mobility we have to
make sure that we're addressing those
factors to avoid a situation where
society
and the members of the society become so
[Music]
disaffected
[Music]
you